13 non notre première année complète de
gouvernement il s'est créé au québec 47
mille emplois alors voilà ça commence
vous allez entend des chiffres à droite
et à gauche et on attend déjà des
chiffres contradictoires pauline marois
vient de dire qu'il s'est créé 44 mille
ans 47 mille emplois philippe couillard
lui prétend que ça va mal et qu'on a
perdu qui dit vrai première épreuve des
faits avec vincent maisonneuve
la chef du pq soutient qu'un nombre
record de québécois occupe actuellement
un emploi
jamais dans toute l'histoire du québec
il n'y a eu autant de monde au travail
qu'en ce moment le québec comptait en
janvier plus de 4 millions de
travailleurs il s'agit en effet d'un
nombre record mais ça ne veut rien dire
puisque la population grossit à chaque
année pour vérifier si l'affirmation de
la chef du pq est vrai nous avons à la
suggestion d'économistes calculer la
proportion de travailleurs par rapport à
la population âgée de 15 à 64 ans et
c'est vrai depuis 20 ans le taux
d'emploi par rapport à la population de
15 à 64 ans n'a jamais cessé d'augmenter
il est passé de 62 à 72 %
essentiellement parce que les politiques
familiales québécoise les garderies à 7
$ ont permis aux deux parents d'aller
travailler
le bilan du gouvernement du pq c'est
l'échec le chef du parti libéral
soutient plutôt que le marché de
l'emploi s'est détérioré au cours de la
dernière année
l'emploi on a perdu 67 mille job à temps
plein l'an dernier c'est vrai le québec
en effet perdu 66 1800 emplois temps
plein contre une création de 76 1800
postes à temps partiel bref depuis un an
au québec
la croissance de l'emploi repose
uniquement sur le travail à temps
partiel
on